i did
i did an ayahuasca ceremony a week
before the pandemic you guys know what
ayahuasca is
so i did that i've never done it before
he's done it a couple times you have
okay so did you throw up did you purge
and everything
not crazy but a little bit the first
time yeah did it pull some [ __ ] out of
you though
definitely yeah definitely it's i
i've never done it but i've done a lot
of other psychedelics and
it was i did two night ceremony and i
did not vomit
in fact i didn't have any bad
experiences i
was it was beautiful it was profound i
saw gorgeous creatures running through
running through there i've done i did it
thinking it's gonna find some more [ __ ]
in me
and it didn't pull anything out and at
first i was like disappointed
and then i was really proud of myself
because i realized that's how much work
i've done over the years to
not let this little boy [ __ ] control
the man that i am now and there's a
quote
that changed my [ __ ] life when i
heard it and it's from alan watts who's
this great british philosopher
and it was you have no obligation to be
the person you were five minutes ago
when i think about that quote you have
no obligation to be the person you were
five minutes ago
i realized so much of what i was holding
on to
was from this little angry
rash child that hated himself
and the world around him but i'm not
that person anymore
so why am i still holding on to any of
that yeah wow
i gotta ask what did you learn about
yourself after doing it
or like what was your takeaway it was it
was just like a lot of
release and it was real similar to like
the first time
doing mushrooms like you said it opens
up a very different perspective on on
the world and everything
so it was like for that it was very
similar to that type of experience it
wasn't like it brought out a lot of
stuff i've been burying
but it was like it just felt like a very
peaceful release of everything
he's just a very calming feeling
he smokes an enormous amount of weed so
i think i don't think it
you probably didn't take enough right
he's like a high tolerance oh no you
don't need
too much you don't eat a lot of
ayahuasca dude that's such a
it's so different really oh my god yeah
i mean it is
like yeah it's such a different
experience and
it is six straight hours of blasting
into another universe and the thing is
you do it usually in a room with like
there were like 20 people in the room
that i did it in
um you know and it's still very much
like an illegal thing for the most part
like there's ceremonies that you can
kind of find if you know the right
person
but most people vomit their [ __ ]
brains out or they purge in some way and
you
listen to 20 people in this room
and the next day they're like man all
this guilt and shame was just coming up
and i realized that i was a piece of
[ __ ] to my first wife and then i
shouldn't have treated her like that and
i'm sorry susan i'm sorry
i listened to a girl i listen to a girl
talk about a woman say she was going i
could hear her going through some [ __ ]
because you can hear
people crying people screaming people
you know
having this success whatever experience
it's giving them this woman the next day
because you sit around a group and you
talked about it did
you guys do the same thing yeah we spent
a couple days with it was just me my
buddy and the guy who was like a shaman
who put the whole ceremony on it was
just us three
oh god we spent a couple days in the
woods with him where he lives out there
and then
did it one night before we left and so
it was a cool experience we just hang
out and
[ __ ] played the guitar in the bongos
for a couple hours and [ __ ]
just chilled but this we were talking
about the next day in group
in a circle and you go through every you
don't you're not allowed to comment on
anybody else's experience you just
listen
and then you talk about your own
experience you don't compare yourself to
others or anything like that you know
it's very open it's very
non-judgmental but this woman i knew
i could hear her having a rough time she
kept asking for help from the shaman she
was crying a lot
and when she talked about what happened
to her she
said that she was stuck in the holocaust
where her grandmother had been
persecuted and killed
and she was in basically a concentration
camp experiencing everything her
grandmother went through
and this generational trauma that had
been stuck in her from her grandmother
to her mother to now her was coming out
of her
in this very you know
almost violent way because that [ __ ] had
been stuck in her
for years since birth basically
and then she got to release that and i
dreamed i drove her home she didn't have
a ride home i drove her home
the next day and we talked i was like i
mean
she was like she was she was still very
heavy
but you could tell like weight had been
lifted you know from just having this
experience
and that's the thing is people you
people have all kinds of different
experiences on it but if you give
yourself
to a psychedelic and you allow it to
take the work that's the whole thing is
you can't fight whatever it's trying to
show you you have to
just give yourself and allow it to come
and know that it's not gonna kill you
you
are gonna be okay just sit down and hold
tight and breathe your way through it
you're gonna be fine i always say
there's no such thing as a bad trip
there's challenging trips i mean it's a
bad trip if you [ __ ] decide to get in
your car
and do something really stupid like you
know you bite your friend's [ __ ] face
off you're like
is this like is this a hot is this gun a
hot dog let me try to eat it
yeah you know like yeah then you're
having a bad trip but as long as you're
in a safe situation
challenging you're gonna go through some
[ __ ] but it's gonna teach you
about yourself yeah i think that's the
most important thing to take away from
all of that is just like
you know allow the experience to happen
be open
and try not to be afraid of it if
possible you just got to go with the
flow and that's everything in life
right so how did this girl inherit this
trauma from her grandmother was it
because her grandmother like talked to
her mother about it who talked to her
about it or was it
generational trauma is a very real thing
you know if you
there's so much of what we are is passed
down in our genetics
and if you're a person who is holding on
to these horrible things that have
happened to you or your family
there is a big part of that that is
inside of you and
a lot of that will inherently get
transferred into your kin and into other
people that you you know
just because of just in the same way
that you
you know that i have blue eyes that
person was like
had part of her grandmother's holocaust
experience
within her and that is a
terrifying thing especially if you don't
know where what it is
and that's the thing without ayahuasca
she probably never would have learned
that she was holding on to that she's
like
she's just walking around thinking like
why am i unhappy
why are things not you know going the
way i want them to why this why
because that is part of what's going on
inside of you
if you talk to a lot of uh a lot of
minorities feel this right is they have
like
like talk to uh black people about they
are direct descendants of slavery and
stuff like that and there is this part
of them
that will never feel completely free
because they have this because they came
from that
and it's it's just this weird thing that
we
as humans like we you know that's what
we get
we get we get there we get some of the
stuff that they look like
but we get a lot of their personality
too
and part of their personality is gonna
be wrapped up in the experiences they've
been through and if they didn't deal
with their [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] gonna give it to you
you